[Music]
so the white house has directed
agencies to refer to the biden
administration as the biden harris
administrations when was the last time
a president demanded that his vice
president get half the credit let's see
never not once in american history in
fact the opposite is always true
so it raises pretty deep questions like
who's running the government
who's really in charge at times it does
seem like a third barack obama term
just a few months ago obama hinted at
what this might look like
people would ask me knowing what you
know now do you wish like you had a sec
a third term um
and i i used to say you know what if if
i could make an arrangement
where um i had a i had a
uh stand in a front man or front woman
and
they had an earpiece in and i was just
in my basement in my sweats
looking through the stuff and then i
could sort of deliver the lines but
somebody else was
uh doing all the talking and ceremony
i'd be fine with that yeah
kind of like a marionette somebody
doesn't really know what's going on and
then he could kind of control everything
through that unknowing person
just spitballing here just just to
daydream fantasy
viktor davis hansen is a fellow at the
hoover institution we're happy to have
him on tonight
professor thanks so much for coming on
have you i mean you follow the stuff
you're a historian
has any american president ever
voluntarily decided to share half the
credit
no is the answer why is this one doing
it
i don't know but you always count on
barack obama to be his uh
most candid and worst critic of himself
but you know
this is fought with irony and karma
because we've got to remember that the
same media that's
created this cocoon around the biden
candidacy the transition the presidency
introduced the whole idea to us that you
could invoke the 25th amendment and
remove donald trump that was nine days
after his
inauguration we were told he was
non-compost mintes remember bandy
dr bandy lee from yale was going to say
he was a sociopath and
rod rosenstein and andrew mccabe were
going to wear a wire to catch him
as incompetent and then get rid of him
through the 25th amendment
and he even took the montreal cognitive
assessment test and aced it to show the
world that he wasn't now that same media
is now doing just the opposite they're
shielding us from knowledge and we had
it
a little bit a glimpse during the
transition that there were cognitive
issues
with joe biden but such as it is now
about half the country
tucker pole that they don't have
confidence in
joe biden's cognitive abilities that
which begs the question
who is running the country and is it
jill biden playing the role of edith
wilson in 1919 when
woodrow wilson for the last basically
the last 19 months of his administration
was stroke ridden and inert
is she the conduit that funnels out
information
is it as you said is it kamela harris
and her team
they have this psychological tick of
referring to herself as president harris
or
the harris biden and that is shared by
you know joe biden himself
or is it senior statesman uh barack
obama who can't resist any current event
to weigh in and who has stocked this
administration with a lot of his former
employees i don't have that answer but
it's getting a little scary because
we just had a debacle in anchorage where
the chinese ate our lunch and a
diplomatic tit for tat
and then in their way of thinking if a
president the most important secretary
is the
secretary of defense the most important
agency and their way of thinking is the
pentagon when the president can't
remember either
in trips three times uh they they may
get the wrong impression you know they
did that with john kennedy in 61 in june
he said he got beat up by khrushchev and
13 months later we had the cuban missile
crisis so
i'm worried it's just not it's not a
media psycho drama anymore it's really
has
geo-strategic and security implications
if our enemies are worried about or not
worried but anxious
to know just how in control joe biden is
of the presidency
that is such a good point i i feel sorry
for biden and i don't want to attack him
and i mean that but it's just
breathtaking it's all happening right in
front of us everyone's pretending it's
not happening but
but i think i think you're right i think
it is happening viktor davis hanson i
appreciate it i think it is
thank you thank you